laurent baffie costard versa
ap les gens auteurs réaction je suis là
ce qu'un artiste il est mort et elle a
beaucoup qui meurt ok enfin vous
pourriez au moins à compatir je sais pas
moi
pour elle on peut rien y faire nous
plaçons bon je sais pas mais je veux je
dis toi quelle tristesse
tu as soyez humain quoi on la refait
monsieur eddy mitchell est mort à 15
heures dommage ce qu'on appelle un fan
de la première heure je me dis mitchell
à l'époque des chaussettes noires
surtout - terme ont fait la preuve sa
disparition aujourd'hui c'est un drame
pour vous dommage
c'est dommage c'est votre peine à votre
émotion monsieur merci beaucoup
j'ai bien un accident de chasse dans ses
toilettes un accident de voir les
chasses dans ses toilettes
la compagnie johnnie walker a déjà perdu
quatre points en bourse
voilà je laboure il connaît assez
d'effet immédiat de la mort 2 eddy
mitchell qui était le plus gros
consommateur de johnny walker
ah bon c'est vrai il est mort qu'est ce
qui était arrivé comment s'est tiré une
balle dans l'anus aujourd'hui à 15h en
voyant les scores des ventes de patrick
bruel n'a pas supporté les records
pourquoi mbaye dans l'anus le cerveau et
en désespoir de cause il s'est tiré une
balle dans l'anus
j'ai rien à vous lire et démissionner
mort monsieur ça vous vous en foutez
j'aurais préféré que ce soit george
habache en ce qui concerne mon avis pas
du trou en ce qui concerne eddy mitchell
vous n'êtes pas de mon avis la question
est réglée et à cri eddy mitchell ça me
fait de la peine au dessus aussi
je n'ai pas de train ouais vous allez
olla mais vous êtes bien curieux à ses
journalistes
monsieur alors vous vous adressiez un
officier de la légion d'honneur
un grand commandeur de la légion
d'honneur alors alors qu'il est s'il
vous plaît pas mais parce que moi aussi
j'ai des fines ce circuit n'est pas des
feed
moi c'est pas un pitch mais il est
collector le vaudou les changes
je voulais échanges
costa
déjà tanné cros disons oui beaucoup
et bizarrement les gens aiment beaucoup
ça mais non c'était très long les gens
bien marché si tu veux on leur dit le
roi du rock'n'roll est mort dans un
premier temps a dit ça bon johnny après
on dit non non c est dit et les gens
disent ah vous me fait peur mais on
dirait dans ta compte m'en fais pas ça
tape à côté de ça
non quand tu me dis c'est non non ça a
été témoin de rien les corrections de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus